sakineh
obrigado galera olha eu não sei como é
que começa a falar de um negócio aqui ó
tá vendo 5h hoje teve três são de chope
que engraçado assim conta e por vai
encarar o filho é beleza werner perdi o
ônibus aí fui embora para casa ou de pé
eu passei mal né 3h da manhã em casa é
pouco trabalhoso trabalho ligado aqui
pra ficar melhor três da manhã entre a
casa o trabalho do tre em sessão da sapa
km de talca e gritando corrente foi do
ano seguramente pode estar em causa se
foca no chão chorando eu estou fazendo
armado levou todo - ele sabe o segredo a
mais que quer mostrar que a enterram o
jeans graa também pra casa depois
trabalhar cansa pra cá a cabeça 2 e de
gripe para eu vou pra casa três aumentos
a rússia começou a jogar pedra em mim a
grande pedra em mim essa sim matar se
não foi assassina eu só assim não caiu
sábado eu chegando em catorze quebrar
todo cheio de sangue corte na cabeça
isso aqui vai ver um carro me
perseguindo com o modo de meninice
humana é o palhaço do mal eu passasse
essa saga desses de outubro dia de seu
rasgar minha roupa e fui lá vou comprar
roupa não tinha mais o caixa da loja se
unindo do youtube passar lá tudo em
comprar um carro ou fazer e eu vi um
palhaço assassino meio da rua olga tudo
fake essas [ __ ] busca não porque eu vi
na internet ouvido um palhaço que para
um carro no meio da rua e ele vem
arrastando um modo eu fui assistir e
ouvir para ver seu time não estava
querendo que eu estava escutando eu fui
assistir o diabo o vídeo era um palhaço
arrastando um outro um rock tem medo de
um outro lado do campo está no roteiro
enquanto de limpar rodada o tatá
dirigindo um carro com medo um palhaço
puxando o roto etá em carro como pampers
o fato não porque eu estava no meu carro
e o cara vem infelizmente estava com o
rosto quando eu olhei aquele rolo [ __ ]
que pariu não é no vídeo ela desce do
carro e sai do carro logo rolou quem tem
medo de roubo me diga uma pessoa que já
morreu por causa do vodu da merda cara o
cara gente boa ou a verdade para gente
como rede que roh do carro morreu
foi o caso de um roubo de um rodo como
assim um outro gol foi o carnaval né
[ __ ] fortal lá em fortaleza vinha
passar o rodo vou passar o roteamento de
baixo rodrigo aires morreu
só assim a pessoa a pessoa que tem medo
rodou ela é burra [ __ ] logo entrou
em casa de chinelo enquanto a mãe estava
passando por na casa eo amigo levou a
rodada da manhã aspecto o éton ao entrar
em casa quando a mãe estava limpa me deu
a rodada nas pernas tão violenta que
tangivelmente mas com tanta mas tanta
força e quando bato espera rassad muleta
essa dor
agora pronto assunto aos palhaços o
assassino toda hora aparece uma foto no
facebook falhasse chegaram no brasil eu
deus espalhasse aí botafoto um palhaço
que apareceu na praça em goiânia e
goioxim é um palhaço assassiná-la dos
estados da ba goiânia é fazer o quê em
goiânia a dupla sertaneja
eu mantenho errado
daí já viu eu peguei e até doente o topo
do cara que eu ficar a mancha a nossa
imagem a box nariz vermelho merda foi
culpado esse vídeo é fake oscar não
faria igual aos estados unidos o estado
não possui na bota maquiagem mas slug é
sangue artificial é máscara de silicone
aqui os caras como barbot da marca a
crise mas que a rede bosta 5 real cop-15
todo o grupo entendeu gosta na profissão
discriminada sofrem preconceito cá eu
trabalho todo dia tem de ocorrer todo
mundo pensou eu tinha um sonho e meu
sonho é trabalhar no circo de soleil o
máximo que conseguiu foi a [ __ ] do
circo do marcos tróia aposta de um
transformer conca
[ __ ] ao transformer está na cidade
agora vai possível já de um carro que
desde quando volta este ano a cabeça de
um lado do designer dan e o para sempre
o vosso discriminado que esse movimento
se mata para fazer graça com as pessoas
eu já tô eu vou beber vou bebê eu vou
beber quando só obrigado por informática
hoje eu tô edital [ __ ] se o bebê não
quero saber do quer saber o bebo hoje a
cabo a gripe meta é [ __ ] fazer isso aqui
não como papel não ganhar sempre foi o
processo criminal do trapezista para
dizer só o trapézio na areia também vai
apagar se no trapézio quanto ver as
pessoas não possam preparar essas
pessoas vão se perguntar pese as pessoas
pelo chão pela lona mas não posso eu
parar eu fico com a gente nós não faz
mal a ninguém
o bebê eu vou eu falei que eu já tô eu
tenho médio para os palhaços chegar no
capô tem um palhaço no brasil temos 40
anos ele vende sanduíches a r$40 e
ninguém fala nada por mais aqueles
palhaços ou do medo e eu trabalhou com a
família o nome do meu filho francisco
jozenilton se acha que alguém que tem um
nome de francisco jorge milton vai ser
alguém na vida não vai eu tenho que
trabalhar para dar dinheiro
há anos eu com pós morte o emprego e
agora discriminado então faço aqui um
apelo pelo emprego digno de nota
espalhar por tava nem festa aniversário
ela chama mas não porque meu filho agora
viu no facebook eo youtube fazendo
porque tinha um negócio agora dos
palhaços a sipam assassino é meus óbvia
vida tá uma merda a vida tá uma merda um
show da minha vida entradas e assim lobo
versão brasileira herbert lixo e da fota
então se você concorda comigo que tem
que parar essa bosta de palhaço
assassino clique gostei aqui embaixo
o revelou
graças a deus ó ó ó pior gripe que eu já
peguei na minha vida você tá bem isso
aqui no facebook clique em curtir e
compartilha com quem compartilhar e
escreve o que você acha que tem que
acabar essa merda de pagar 5 tamo junto
obrigado isso pela força por ter deixado
mostrar meu trabalho e tal
[Música]